[Musica]
noi maschi siamo deficienti
lo so che molti di voi lo sanno già lo
so che molte di voi lo sanno già
ma quello che mi interessa raccontarvi
stasera è che noi siamo deficienti nel
senso di stupidi cretini ma proprio nel
senso della parola latina deficere ci
manca qualche cosa noi maschi
la storia ce lo racconta siamo stati da
sempre quelli ai vertici di ogni potere
quasi tutti i decisori politici dire i
comandanti condottieri gli dei i geni
gli inventori gli artisti la stragrande
maggioranza tutti maschi però la storia
la statistica ci raccontano anche
un'altra cosa noi maschi
siamo quelli che vogliamo prima siamo
quelli che moriamo male
vogliamo di più ammazza ti ammazziamo e
moriamo di più ammazzati siamo quelli
che soffriamo di più di depressione e
non lo raccontiamo siamo quelli che si
suicidano di più abbiamo un grande
valore grande potere una grande
visibilità moriamo male
vogliamo ammazzati moriamo presto siamo
deficienti
c'è qualcosa che ci manca siamo
deficienti non ci crediamo furbi
furbissimi alla fine del 1800 abbiamo
inventato una parola femminismo e
abbiamo chiamato con questa parola una
malattia la malattia che avevano gli
uomini che non si comportavano
abbastanza virilmente che manifestavano
caratteri troppo maschili che si
comportavano po troppo da donna e
abbiamo inventato questa parola mentre
già molti femminismi agivano invece per
superare barriere disparità differenze
per concedere a mezza umanità che non
gli aveva diritto possibilità
opportunità le femminismi già
raccontavano che le nostre società
decise maschi avevano prodotto dei
valori culturali che avevano trasformato
le differenze che abbiamo tutti che
abbiamo tutte quelle differenze che ci
rendono unici che ci rendono uniche le
nano trasformate in valori discriminanti
in disparità e strumenti per opprimere
avevano cioè trasformato le differenze
in valori dati a quelle differenze e
avevano costruito una gerarchia mettendo
alcuni di questi valori più in alto di
altri raccontando che c'erano dei valori
più giusti migliori di altri
tanti i femminismi raccontavano ancora
raccontano dopo tanti anni la forza di
questi condizionamenti culturali che
sono ovunque culturali sono nella
letteratura nel cinema nello spettacolo
nel linguaggio nei media nelle nostre
abitudini e le chiacchiere tutti i
giorni e raccontano e le nostre identità
anche prima che noi lasciamo ci
immaginiamo liberi di costruire le
nostre identità
in realtà usiamo dei valori che già
esistono che già ci sono e che noi non
abbiamo deciso e di cui nessuno ci
racconta per esempio quanto fanno male a
qualcun altro a qualcun altro però
proprio perché sono condizionamenti
culturali
tanti i femminismi ci raccontano che noi
possiamo fare qualcosa possiamo
diventare più sensibili di conoscerli
vederli scoprirli
possiamo quindi cambiare le nostre
abitudini i nostri gesti ed evitare
questi valori che noi non abbiamo deciso
come facciamo quindi a liberarci da
questi condizionamenti
dobbiamo ascoltare le differenze e luni
valori che una cultura maschilista ha
dato a quelle differenze
nessuno di noi nessuna di noi decide
dove nascere se dove c'è la guerra dove
c'è la pace
nessuno di noi decide se nascere
benestante o in povertà
nessuno di noi decide da chi nascere chi
sarà nostra madre nessuno di noi decide
quale sarà la sua lingua madre
ma tutti questi condizionamenti ci
plasmano costruiscono la nostra visione
del mondo e noi spesso non pensiamo che
dovremmo un po discutere di queste cose
come facciamo allora scoprirli a vederli
a metterli in discussione ea costruire
noi una identità che troviamo già fatta
dobbiamo ascoltare chi è diverso da noi
io sono un maschio bianco etero cheese
gender divento più libero si ascolto le
donne perché le donne sanno vedere quali
condizionamenti mi sottopone a quali
condizionamenti mi sottopone la mia idea
di essere maschi di vento più libero se
ascolto
l'immigrato perché l'immigrato mi
racconta mi sa vedere i condizionamenti
della mia economia della mia legge al
vento più libero se ascolto la persona
che non è vero che non si riconosce
nella binarie ta che non è cesi gender
perché mi sa dire quanto sono
condizionato da mio sesso del mio genere
dal mio orientamento di vento più libero
se ascolto via un corpo che funziona in
una maniera diversa dalla miniera perché
mi sa dire quanto sono condizionato
dalle mie mani dalle mie gambe dalla mia
lingua dai miei occhi la mie orecchie e
dai neuroni che fanno funzionare insieme
tutte queste cose
quella cultura maschilista neanche detto
già di chi è la colpa se le cose non
vanno bene se le cose non mi vanno bene
lo sappiamo tutti
la colpite le donne europee dei neri
la colpa è degli immigrati colpa dei
poveri europee dei cinesi
la colpa è dei musulmani e tutte queste
categorie che possiamo anche usare
insieme la colpa è delle lesbiche nere
cinesi la colpa è dei gay musulmani la
colpa di non funziona in questo modo le
cose sono un pochino più complesso ma
possiamo farci qualcosa
noi maschi possiamo liberarci insieme da
questi condizionamenti che non abbiamo
scelti perché questi condizionamenti
sono il problema del nostro genere e
sono il problema di tutti gli altri
generi
perché sono diventate quelle quei valori
che opprimono che costringono altri
altre una vita sofferta giustamente
maschi
liberiamoci insieme dalle cose che non
abbiamo scelto ci manca
questa sensibilità verso una differenza
verso qualcosa che ci può raccontare
quello che noi non sappiamo di noi
stessi perché nessuno ce lo racconta
perché nasciamo in una futura che non ce
lo dice ci dice sempre di chi altro è la
colpa
senza farci assumere la responsabilità
di costruire la nostra identità maschi
liberiamoci insieme da quello che ci sta
uccidendo e da quello che sta diventando
qualcosa che rende la vita difficile a
tutti gli altri ea tutte le altre
grazie
[Applauso]